We have covered a fairly large
number of topics in this course.
You might recall this particular
chart from the first lesson.
Let us go through each one of
these circles one-by-one and
see the connections between them.
So, in the fundamentals,
we covered knowledge representations
like semantic networks.
In fact, we used semantic networks to
address two-by-one matrix problems.
Then we covered a series
of problem solving methods.
There's already domain independent
journal purpose methods.
They do not use a lot of knowledge, but
they're very powerful, generate and
test, means-ends analysis,
and problem reduction.
Then we turn to production systems.
They are a specific kind
of cognitive architecture.
Production systems combine reasoning,
learning, and memory.
Production systems to
bolster technology for
developing agents, and
a theory of human computation.
>> Later we talked about planning.
And in order to talk about planning we
first proposed a formal language for
discussing the plan.
It's called formal logic.
We learned about the different rules and
syntax used for
writing formula logical statements.
And learned why this is very important,
that it allows agents to
prove the accuracy of their
conclusions based on a set of axioms.
That gave us a language that we could
then use to talk about planning, and
as we found out actually, the origins of
planning where an agent's making proofs
of why a certain set of actions
would lead to a certain goal.
Here we talked about both partial order
planning and hierarchical planning,
which are two planning methods that
allow agents to make advanced plans for
complex tasks.
And also allows us to reflect on the way
we ourselves plan our actions to complex
environments.
>> Under common sense reasoning we
covered several important lessons.
Frames, understanding,
common sense reasoning and scripts.
Frames is a structured knowledge to
that allows us to do understanding.
Understanding is such
a common every day activity.
We are trying to make sense of
the world, but the world is ambiguous.
The word, take, for example can have so
many different meanings.
We saw how frames allow us to
disambiguate different meanings of
the word take.
Under common sense reasoning
we made every day intuitive
inferences about the world around us.
With understanding and
common sense reasoning,
we're concerned with
sentence-level understanding.
Scripts is more concerned about
discourse-level understanding.
Scripts is an even larger,
just structure knowledge
presentation than frames.
It, too allows us to make
sense of the world around us,
both the physical world and
the social world.
Frames also came up in some
of the other lessons, and
particularly came up in
the lesson on production systems,
when we were trying to
represent episodic knowledge.
It also came up in the lesson on
configuration, when we were trying to
represent plans, and the variables of
various plans that can take values.
>> We talked about learning in many
lessons throughout this course.
But certain lessons were explicitly and
solely concerned with learning.
We started off by talking about learning
by recording cases, where an agent could
build up a case library of its own prior
experiences to use for future reasoning.
That formed a foundation of
analogical reasoning as well,
that we'll talk about in a second.
We also talked about incremental
concept learning and
version spaces,
two different learning methods for
learning about information that's
coming in incrementally, or bit by bit.
That was one of our foundational
principles of this class that we
discussed at the beginning and
that we'll revisit in a few minutes.
We also talked about
classification under learning,
which is one of the most
ubiquitous problems in AI.
We talked about how classification
involves grouping large combinations of
percepts into equivalence classes,
to allow for easier action selection.
Learning also can open several other
lessons that we did throughout this
class, including production systems,
key spaced reasoning, explanation based
learning, analogical reasoning, and
learning about correcting mistakes.
Metareasoning was also deeply connected
to learning, where we could learn from
our own experiences by analyzing
our own prior thought processes.
>> As David just said,
analogical reasoning is another
major topic connected with learning.
We talked about learning
by recording cases.
We are simply assimilating cases
by recording them in a growing
case library.
As a new problem comes, we use methods
like nearest neighbor to retrieve
the closest case, and
it invoked that case with a new problem.
We talked about case-based reasoning,
in which we not only retrieved the case,
but we also tweak it, or
modify it in small ways in
order to achieve a new goal.
In explanation-based learning,
we saw how we could connect
instances to kinds of definitions.
We constructed explanations that
told us how instance is an example
of a given concept.
This involved both abstraction and
transfer.
We also connected explanation-based
learning to creativity.
Analogical reasoning made
[INAUDIBLE] abstraction and
transfer even more explicit.
We talked about cross
analogical transfer for
example from the solar system
to the atomic structure.
We saw that when needed,
rich mental models in order to be
able to do an analogical transfer.
We concluded the lesson on
analogical reasoning by connecting
it with analogical design or
design by analogy.
And analogical reasoning too is
closely connected to creativity.
>> Our discussion of visuospatial
reasoning started with our unit on
constraint propagation.
Constraint propagation
was a very abstract and
general way of propagating constraints
to make sense of a new situation, and
it comes up uniquely
in visual reasoning.
Or we use line labeling to make
sense of 3D scenes even if they're
presented in 2D.
Where we use line labeling to make sense
of three dimensional scenes even if
they're presented in
only two dimensions.
We also how constraint
propagation can be used for
natural language understanding.
And we referenced how we might
also use it to understand music or
tactile information.
Then in visuospatial reasoning
we expanded on these notions to
discuss whether it would be
possible to reason about the world
without extracting propositions.
This involved looking at scenes in
the world where there was no explicit
causality, like a glass that's
been spilled on the table.
We can infer what happened,
but there's nothing in the visual scene
that tells us exactly how it arose.
Similarly, we also discuss how this
could apply to other modalities,
like tactile information or
musical information.
>> In the unit on design and creativity,
we considered lessons in configuration,
diagnosis, design and creativity.
You may recall that in configuration,
we were worried about very routine,
everyday kind of designs, and
we did that kind of design
by having a library of clients at
different levels of abstraction.
We selected a plan at a high level of
abstraction, assign values to some of
the variables, and then refine the plan
at the next door level abstraction.
All the components were known,
we had to decide on the arrangement
of the components of configuration.
In diagnosis, we were given data
about a malfunctioning system and
we had to identify the fault
responsible for that malfunctioning.
We took two views of diagnosis,
classification and abduction.
In the classification view,
this data was mapped into
equal classes that acted like
hypotheses for this data.
In abduction, we composed this
elementary hypothesis into a composite
hypothesis that could best
explain the entire data.
Design thinking refers to thinking
about problems that are ill-defined and
open-ended, and under-constrained.
In design thinking, the problem and
solution often co-evolve.
The problem doesn't remain fixed.
The solution evolves, but
that in turns it leads to improving
the understanding of the problem,
both our understanding of the problem
and solution evolve together.
We cut across creativity in
terms of novelty, value, and
the non-obviousness of the results.
We discuss the criteria under which we
would consider an agent to be creative.
And we saw how many of the techniques
that you have learned in this particular
class can compose the fundamental
processes of creativity.
Like analogical reasoning, like visual
special reasoning, like meta-reasoning.
>> Then we close the class by
talking about meta-cognition.
Meta-cognition enable the agents to
reason about their own reasoning, or
think about their own thinking, or have
knowledge of their own knowledge base.
We started out by talking about
learning by correcting mistakes.
Or an agent can look at a mistake
that's been made in the past,
isolate the mistake,
explain the mistake and
then fix the mistake so
that it didn't happen again.
This was one narrow instance of
the broader idea of meta-reasoning.
In meta-reasoning, we talked about
metacognition could bring together many
of the different methods that we
talked about throughout this class.
Meta-reasoning enabled an agent to
look at a new problem and select
which of its many strategies would
be best for addressing that problem.
It also would allow an agent to
integrate multiple different methods of
reasoning at different
levels of distraction.
We also talked about what how
meta-reasoning operates is also the way
in which meta-reasoning operates.
Meta-reasoning can reason
about case based reasoning, or
it can reason using
case based reasoning.
It could, for example, use production
rules to conduct case based reasoning.
In this way it could integrate
many different methods
at many different levels of instruction.
Finally, this set up a notion of
ethics in artificial intelligence.
As we're building AI agents
that are starting to have real,
human level intelligence,
what are the ethical issues?
What should we think about replacing
certain human jobs with robots,
or what should we think about developing
robots that can interact with us on
an everyday basis in the natural world?
Under what conditions would we consider
these agents to actually be human-like?
>> This summarizes 30 topics
that we covered in this class,
which is quite a lot.
Of course, there is a lot more to
talk about each of these 30 topics
than we have covered so far.
Therefore we have provided readings for
each of the topics.
And you are welcome to
pursue the readings for
whatever topic that
interests you the most.
We would also love to hear about
your views about this on the forum.